let's jump back this we got we have
another story that I really think we
this is terrible we need to cover this
story man so this is from the Gateway
pond it I am NOT a fan of the game a
pundit because they have published
questionable things in the past however
the story is written by Cassandra
Fairbanks who I know and trust and I did
personally confirm this story the reason
I'm using this segment instead of just
showing you the actual Facebook page the
headline is black lives matter
sociopaths raid Facebook page of young
mom murdered for saying all lives matter
torment her family I could pull up the
Facebook but it's my facebook with all
my messages and friends and stuff and
you know personal stuff but I did
confirm this isn't legit 100% Cassandra
she hit me up and she was like dude you
got to see this is insane I don't even
know if I can show it these people are
posting they're posting crazy stuff
sells bad for those that aren't familiar
with this story there was a young woman
in Indiana she was walking by canal
apparently walked past some some other
people who said black lives matter to
her she responded with all lives matter
argument breaks out apparently both
groups were armed so they like chill
down said no no no we don't want to know
fist-bumped then when this woman and her
people you know her friend or fee answer
whatever walked away once they got to
this bridge the other group turned ran
back and opened fire shooting her three
times one in the head she's dead
why is it the story national news you
want to know it's even crazier my it was
run it was posted to Reddit on unpopular
opinion saying the story of women killed
by a black lives matter supporter for
saying all has matter should be national
news removed for trolling Wow for
trolling trolling seriously reddit has
become a cesspool wasteland of just
garbage yeah you know I guess you're not
allowed to post anything about POC
violation of administrators at wide
policies yep so they removed it and now
the story is on their face on the
Facebook page for this woman these these
supporters these black lives matter
people are showing up and saying the
rest of you are next and things like
that that's terrible they're posting it
there's thousands of comments so Terry
Crews was absolutely right a way we got
to make sure black lives that it doesn't
become black lives better like that you
know what this is what it really annoys
me it's like people think when someone
says black lives matter
they're saying other lives don't matter
and that's not true black lives do
matter period you know and then when
someone responds with all lives matter
that is also true they're both true
statements they're it's like I'm fine
with Wolf
I'm nothing wrong with either statement
you know and it's like everything has
been weaponized to to divide us and
split us and and we have to figure out a
way to step back from that that
weaponization of these words that are
all true all lives matter black lives
matter all of them every single one of
those everybody everybody matters you
know but it's a tribal as a tribal thing
yeah it is and that's and that's why
somebody would die I don't I don't know
if I can actually show some of these
posts because they're they're brutally
racist men that I'm not gonna show them
no I can't do it it's it's it's it's
like hardcore racism pro-death you know
gloating see this is crazy you know
we've we've talked about this many times
like and even in that documentary that
we're gonna talk about next
Uncle Tom goes yes goes into a lot of
like racism was not really around and
it's it's reared its ugly head
not because of Trump everyone is trying
to bring up well hold on hold on right
well I mean there's a lot of information
that's true to bring that up hello
everybody I say racism was around of
course but just say that racism doesn't
exist I am NOT saying that racism exists
here's the best part what they complain
about institutional racism right there
making it yes they're making the
institutional racism exactly I bring up
a million times but California visit man
I wish I had this pulled up the vote to
repeal California civil rights law right
it's amazing because it says yes and no
for support or oppose on ballotpedia and
right yes would strike the following
text the state shall not discriminate
against a person ball blonde or like
that's crazy right there they say
repealing the Civil Rights Act and they
are creating institutional racism
exactly and they're doing some smart
claiming they're fighting against it
yeah so so here's a no-no even even
worse they're convincing everyone else
that that's that's what they're doing
that's how the ran they are convinced
the racists figured it out that if you
want these laws and everybody hates
racism you know you need to invert what
racism is confuse the people so I was
talking to a friend of mine and I was
talking about their support for black
lives matter activism yeah and I said I
understand the surface level of you know
what your support represents yeah but do
you understand what they're proposing
what the the changes they're proposing
are the activism they're funding the the
organizers know okay you need to
understand that when you go out and you
support them you're empowering things
that you're not paying attention to
exactly maybe you agree maybe you don't
but surprise surprise whenever I show
people to repeal 209 they say oh my
that's insane
yeah and I'm like well maybe you should
be paying attention to what these people
are doing in your name when you stand a
next time waving your little flags and
defending them boom but they don't do it
no and this is what you get you get you
get an escalation of just the craziest
craziest stuff so you know I'll give us
I'll give a shout-out to Jessica
Whitaker's family they've raised 66
thousand dollars I'm glad to see it it's
a sad story
there's no no amount of money is ever
gonna bring back you know this person's
gonna give that child their mother back
gonna get that father as a daughter
one-year-old yeah
three three or a three year old is that
wrong maybe I'm father lost his life a
man lost his fiancee a little girl lost
her lost her mom I mean this is just the
amount of people that have lost their
lives in the past month dozens I'm
speechless
I'm angry it pisses me off that none of
them matter exactly none of them matter
none of them and they're all racist and
look at everybody's dying everyone's
getting killed nobody cares
they're not out there fighting they're
still just chanting George Floyd's name
who as far as I'm concerned is dying in
vain well George Floyd got justice right
all the cops got arrested yep and some
serious charges yeah
no one supported them right no one did
the only one who did and they went out
and then a bunch of people died and
where was the condemnation David Dorn
David Doran good guy there's countless
of names yep III I can't even I don't
even know where to begin none of their
lives mattered and why why is that the
cops I'll tell you that I don't those
lie no matter I don't understand that no
one knows where the only thing that
makes sense they're their lives
obviously matter you ask anybody and
I'll say of course their lives mattered
but but exactly don't you but that now
if you want if you want someone's name
plastered all over the press then I want
other victims names in the press usually
don't get to tell me what name is the
most important to plaster all over the
country and write and riot over if we
you know that this and isn't the problem
this woman you what the crazy thing
about this is what this story was broken
I believe by Cassandra Fairbanks you
know like a week after it happened
really because no one knew the local
reporters didn't explain what happened
they said due to an argument over black
lives matter in language and then
Cassandra contacted the family and they
were like she said all lives matter so
they shot her and then the Daily wire
and the Daily Caller and a bunch of
other journalists confirmed the family
said she said all lives matter it's
messed up they shot and killed her or
that guy in Wisconsin who was targeted
because he was riding a Harley
whatever Wilson Hills white guy driving
a Harley someone targeted and ran him
over and killed him and his response was
well all white supremacist ride Harley's
and it's like the guy said yes like are
you kidding me and riding riding like a
heart like a hog yeah and it's like oh
well all white guys on so how do you
bikes like that are supremacist it's
like yeah where are you getting that
information from this is what happens
when you let this kind of psychotic
identitarian ISM take over the media
yeah and they runs them up that is
racism hello that is racism
they're targeting they change that he
pacifically of a certain race that isn't
their own because they think they're
there need to be killed
they changed the definition of racism
that way you can't you can't argue
anymore
well they didn't they didn't change my
deaf
of racism didn't change the dictionary
changed it this is the game they're
playing sure and they're gaining the
ground they're taking the high ground
the dictionary now includes a circuitous
definition of the word racism right so
it doesn't make any sense
exactly in reference uh it's it's a
recursive loop Hey the definition of
racism in the new mirror in the new
merriam-webster references itself its
own word in the definition they're
breaking everything yep they're
terrorizing the American check the
citizens check this out and it's
terrible economist YouGov poll
Association slogans do the following
slogans carry positive or a negative
association to you all lives matter
positive total 53% male and female 54
and 53 high school or less is 62 but
look at this post-grad is 38% that's
actually amazing posts grads they're
college educated people they tend to be
the woke ultra lefties yeah and 38% have
a positive association of all lives
matter okay that's interesting so not
all of them go crazy and look at this
here's here's the best one let's go to
race 58% positive black for all lives
matter yep interesting yep and Hispanic
has 47 other is Ford I guess other is
Asian sure great thanks you go white is
55 percent sixty five-plus is seventy
percent
let me see if I can scroll down and see
if they have the the Association for
black lives matter here we go
association for black lives matter among
the black community is 73 percent so
this is amazing it seems like the black
community understands that both are
positive you know that's good at least
mostly they both are positive not
everybody but they are yeah and look at
this high school or less has a 42% some
college of 44 percent positive
association with black lives matter
the total is only forty eight percent
check that out so more people think all
lives matter is positive then and yep
the other way around so for all forty
eight percent of people have a positive
view of black lives matter 30 percent
have a negative view all lives matter is
a 23 percent negative and a 53 percent
positive dare I say all lives matter
is more popular more more more likely to
be associated with positivity than black
lives matter I want to do the same poll
with no lives matter it's gonna be all
nice lively joking no like in the scheme
of things like what are we you know no
lives matter like that's the great span
of the universe like I'm I always those
who follow me on Twitter which you can
follow me right there Adam Craig ler you
know I post a lot of space stuff and I'm
constantly thinking about space about
how what our position is on in this
immense immense place which is the
universe like we are nothing we are
lucky to be alive on this this bubble
you know of oxygen you know flying
around the Sun we are so lucky to be
here
nitrogen atom Oh skew night it's what 77
actual actually atom it's nitrogen its
[Laughter]
nitrogen anyway we're lucky to be on the
little pale blue dot we were very much
so you're right absolutely we are all
lucky to be alive right now we thanks
for checking out this clip from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you